This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. For over a decade now, listeners of this show have heard me say that we're headquartered in beautiful downtown, or now uptown, Oakland, California. These days, the 99% Invisible team is spread all across the US and Canada. Hey Chris. But a few of us still live and work in Oakland. And despite how far flung the 99-I-P-I team is,
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。十年多来，本节目的听众一直听我说，我们的总部设在美丽加州奥克兰市的市中心，或者现在是上城。如今，99%隐形团队已经分散在美国和加拿大的各地。嘿，克里斯。但我们仍有一些人住在奥克兰并在这里工作。尽管99-I-P-I团队的成员天各一方，
there's just something about the city that feels like the spiritual home of our show. I think what makes Oakland home for me is this incredible diversity of like peoples and places that are all sort of contained within it. This is Alexis Madrigal, an Oakland resident himself and one of the hosts of the local public radio call-in show Forum on KQED. He also happens to be a long time friend of mine. When I first moved here, you know, 12, 13 years ago, it was kind of like a quarter of the population was white,
但这座城市总有一种感觉，像是我们节目的精神家园。我想，让奥克兰成为我的家园的原因，是这里蕴含着的各种各样的人群和地方那种不可思议的多样性。这是亚历西斯·马德里加尔，他本人就是奥克兰居民，也是本地公共电台KQED连线节目《论坛》的主持人之一。他碰巧也是我的老朋友。你知道的，我刚搬到这里时，大约12、13年前，差不多四分之一的人口是白人，
a quarter of the population was black, a quarter was Latino, and like a quarter was Asian. You know, there's tons of working class people, there's tons of non-working class people, and they're all kind of shoved into the same place, right in view of this kind of glittering future city of San Francisco, and we're kind of like the backlot, you know, and I love, that part of it always made me feel
四分之一的人口是黑人，四分之一是拉丁裔，还有大约四分之一是亚裔。你知道的，这里有成吨的工人阶级，有成吨的非工人阶级，他们都被塞进了同一个地方，就在那座金光闪闪的未来城市旧金山的眼皮底下，而我们就像是片场后面的布景，你知道的，我喜欢——那一部分总是让我感到
quite at home, and also it really helped me like fall in love with the city. When you cross the Bay Bridge from San Francisco to Oakland, you don't see some flashy skyline. Instead, your eye is either drawn up to the densely forested hills or down towards the port where a series of rail lines, shipping containers, and massive industrial cranes lie on the shore. The cranes have become the official and unofficial symbol of the city. People spray paint them around, people have them on shirts.
相当有归属感，这也确实帮我爱上了这座城市。当你从旧金山经由海湾大桥来到奥克兰时，你不会看到什么浮华的天际线。相反，你的目光要么会被吸引到树木葱郁的山丘上，要么会投向港口——那里有一连串的铁路线、集装箱和巨大的工业起重机静静地伫立在岸边。这些起重机已经成为了这座城市官方和非官方的象征。人们到处喷涂它们的图案，把它们印在衬衫上。
It does represent us in some crucial way. And in part it's because any route into the city, basically, you end up seeing them. They are kind of our skyscrapers, right? They are this thing which is out of scale with like human life. In the shadow of those cranes lies the neighborhood of West Oakland. It's a predominantly black working class community. And in Alexis's new book, The Pacific Circuit, he writes about how this neighborhood has been shaped by the global economic forces that connect Oakland to the rest of the world.
在某种关键的层面上，它确实代表了我们。部分原因是因为基本上你进城的任何路线，最后都会看到它们。它们有点像我们的摩天大楼，对吧？它们是那种与人类生命尺度不相称的东西。在这些起重机的阴影下，坐落着西奥克兰社区。这是一个以黑人为主的工人阶级社区。在亚历西斯的新书《太平洋环线》中，他写道这个社区是如何被将奥克兰与世界其他地方联系起来的全球经济力量所塑造的。
Every year, billions of dollars worth of stuff gets loaded into a container and onto a cargo ship destined for the port of Oakland. The supply chain that keeps goods flowing between Asia and the Bay Area has transformed life as we know it today. Products are cheaper, they arrive at your door in a flash. But all that has a cost. And in West Oakland, the impacts of global trade are felt by residents every day. The story of this neighborhood and its relationship to the port next door tells us a lot about the trade-off cities have made in service of economic growth. It's also a
每年，价值数十亿美元的各种货物被装进集装箱，运上驶往奥克兰港的货轮。保持亚洲和湾区之间货物畅通的供应链，已经改变了我们今天所知的日常生活。产品更便宜了，它们转瞬之间就能送到你的门前。但这一切都是有代价的。在西奥克兰，居民们每天都能感受到全球贸易带来的影响。这个社区的故事及其与毗邻港口的关系，让我们深刻认识到城市为了追求经济增长而做出的权衡。这也是一个
place where people have had to learn how to push back against these enormous financial forces to save their neighborhood, their neighbors, and themselves. So I was hoping that we could start off by going like way back. How far back you want to go? I think I can go all the way back. Let's kind of go all the way back. Railroads. I mean, kind of.
人们不得不学会如何反抗这些巨大的金融力量，以拯救他们的社区、他们的邻居和他们自己的地方。所以我希望我们能从很久以前开始讲起。你想回到多久以前？我想我可以一直追溯到最初。让我们回到最开始吧。铁路。我是说，某种程度上。
I mean, so talk to me about West Oakland. How did this part of the city end up becoming, like, the center of black life in the Bay Area? Yeah, so Oakland became the black center of the Bay Area basically because of the railroads, right? I mean, people quite famously know about, like, sort of the porters, and the porters had a union, and many of them were black.
我是说，跟我聊聊西奥克兰吧。这座城市的这一部分是怎么最终变成湾区黑人生活中心的呢？是的，奥克兰之所以成为湾区的黑人中心，基本上是因为铁路，对吧？我的意思是，人们非常清楚地知道，比如那些搬运工，搬运工们有一个工会，而且他们当中很多都是黑人。
And so that was kind of mixed in with like all kinds of other folks who had come as you know immigrants to West Oakland and specifically to sort of the very western part of West Oakland and just so people can orient themselves This is the part that's like right on the bay. Yeah, right next to the port Yes like right on the bay and right next to the port. Yeah, so over time, as more black people came, they just kind of, you know, in the way that many migrants do, ended up kind of clumping in this particular part of the city. And of course, there were racist restrictions, which got tighter later, but it kind of established the core,
所以这与作为移民来到西奥克兰的形形色色的人混杂在了一起，特别是来到西奥克兰最西边的部分。为了让大家搞清楚方位，这就是紧挨着海湾的那一部分？是的，就在港口旁边。是的，就像紧挨着海湾和港口一样。所以随着时间的推移，随着越来越多的黑人到来，他们就像许多移民一样，最终在这个城市的特定部分聚集了下来。当然，还有种族限制，后来变得更加严格，但它基本上确立了核心，
and then more and more people kind of came to that. And you started to see this kind of you know, if you've researched other black areas in the West people inevitably call a street with lots of black commercial activity the Harlem of the West and so it became one of these Harlem's of the West along 7th Street in West Oakland and what that meant was there were places where you could get oftentimes southern food because most of the people who were coming up were from the south. So you could get ribs and you could get things that you maybe wouldn't find in the rest of the Oakland area and music and bars and there were unions and there were just kind of an integrated whole
然后越来越多的人来到了这里。你开始看到这种——你知道的，如果你研究过西部的其他黑人社区，人们不可避免地会把拥有大量黑人商业活动的街道称为“西部的哈莱姆”。所以它成了西奥克兰第七街沿线的那些“西部的哈莱姆”之一。这意味着那里有你可以买到南方食物的地方——通常是南方食物，因为大多数北上的人都来自南方。所以你可以买到烤排骨，还能买到你在奥克兰其他地方可能找不到的东西，以及音乐和酒吧，那里有工会，还有一种融为一体的
of black life took place really right there along 7th Street in West Oakland, which then of course as more and more black migrants came, especially to work in the shipyards World War II, that made that part of town into a very dense, both lovely and also very difficult place to live as well because it was right in the industrial grime as intended by city planners at the time. Right. So let's talk about that. How did Oakland city planners in the industrial grime as intended by city planners at the time. Right. So let's talk about that. How did Oakland city planners in the early part of the 20th century segregate,
黑人生活，实实在在就发生在西奥克兰第七街沿线。随后，当然，随着越来越多的黑人移民到来，特别是在第二次世界大战期间去造船厂工作，这使得那片城区变成了一个人口稠密、既可爱又非常难熬的居住地，因为它正如当时城市规划者所意图的那样，直接处于工业油烟和污垢之中。没错。那我们来谈谈这个。20世纪早期的奥克兰城市规划者是如何在当时的工业油烟中，将黑人居民隔离、
divide, and zone black residents into some of the roughest parts of the city? Yeah. So I have Shaddock, who was the planning engineer in Oakland during this early New Deal period in which the federal government was running all of these kinds of research programs to understand the housing stock and populations inside cities. And part of that task was assembling all of this data on every block in basically urban America.
划分并区划到城市中最糟糕的一些区域的？是的。所以当时有沙达克，他是新政早期奥克兰的规划工程师，当时联邦政府正在运行所有这些研究项目，以了解城市内部的住房存量和人口。其中一项任务就是收集基本上全美城市中每一个街区的所有这些数据。
And what they ended up finding in Oakland was that you could segregate off the area where black people lived intermixed with some white people of various ethnic groups, from the area that was still mostly white. What they end up recommending is essentially a freeway to cut off the black population and hem them against the industrial shoreline. This is the freeway that was built in the 1950s that basically split West Oakland in half.
他们最终在奥克兰发现的是，你可以把黑人居住的区域——其中也穿插着各种族裔的白人——与大部分仍是白人的区域隔离开来。他们最终的建议基本上是用一条高速公路来切断黑人人口，并把他们逼向工业海岸线。这就是在20世纪50年代建造的高速公路，它基本上把西奥克兰劈成了两半。
I mean, today the neighborhood is still surrounded by highways, but for a long time, one of those highways ran kind of right through the middle of the community and it pinned a sort of the very western part of West Oakland right against the water. That's right. I think it's worth remembering for people
我是说，如今这个社区仍然被高速公路包围着，但在很长一段时间里，其中一条高速公路就穿过了社区的正中间，它把西奥克兰最西边的那一部分紧紧地钉在水边。没错。我想值得提醒人们的是，
that like, while it might sound nice to live by the shoreline, the industrial shoreline in this sort of pre-environmental regulations era was disgusting. And so you had the railroads running through. You had factories doing all kinds of stuff. This is still an industrial city. And then you had that the water itself was toxic, and there are sewer outflows, and there's
尽管住在海岸线旁听起来可能很美好，但在这种前环保法规时代，工业海岸线是令人作呕的。所以那里有铁路穿过。有工厂在做各种各样的事情。这仍然是一个工业城市。然后水本身也是有毒的，有下水道排污口，还有
all kinds of stuff happening there. And so this is the one area of town where essentially Oakland city planners said, this is where black people can live, and this is where black people must live. So black residents of Oakland were living right by the port. And around that time in the 1950s, the port was also seeing a sort of
各种各样的事情在那里发生。所以这是镇上的唯一一个区域，奥克兰的城市规划者基本上说：这就是黑人可以住的地方，这也是黑人必须住的地方。因此，奥克兰的黑人居民就住在港口旁边。大约在20世纪50年代的那个时候，港口也正在经历航运业的
revolution in the shipping industry with containerization and We've actually talked a lot about containerization on the show before with you in fact But basically instead of moving a bunch of small individual boxes on and off of cargo ships Everything was going inside of this like one big box. And those big boxes, or containers, would get dropped off in a yard nearby and a bunch of trucks would come by and take them away. But for this whole operation to work, you basically need a lot of land
革命，伴随着集装箱化。事实上，我们以前已经在节目中和你一起详细讨论过集装箱化了。但基本上，不再是将一箱箱小型的独立货物搬上搬下货轮，而是所有东西都被装进了这一个大箱子里。而这些大箱子，也就是集装箱，会被卸在附近的堆场里，然后一堆卡车会开过来把它们拉走。但要让整个运作流程顺利进行，你基本上需要大量的土地
to store those containers on. Absolutely right. You need hundreds of acres of more or less useless land right on the coast of a major city. You know, it's like, and how do you find that? And basically the answer that the whole containerization trade came up with was to implant in poor neighborhoods
来存放这些集装箱。完全正确。你需要几百英亩大城市海岸边或多或少没有什么用处的土地。你知道的，就像，你如何找到这样的土地？基本上，整个集装箱化贸易得出的答案是，将它们植入贫困社区中
in places adjacent to the big city. So if you think about the first two big container points, you have Newark, which of course is right, you know, outside New York City, and you have Oakland. And so it was the plan, basically, of Oakland City planners for as long as they had had dreams to push out the population of West Oakland so that Oakland's industrial base could take over that whole area. They would call it completely unfit for human habitation, when it was basically the densest residential neighborhood in the East Bay.
紧邻大城市的地方。所以如果你想想前两个大的集装箱枢纽，你有纽瓦克，当然它就在纽约市郊外，你还有奥克兰。因此，奥克兰城市规划者的计划基本上是——只要他们还怀有梦想——把西奥克兰的人口赶出去，以便奥克兰的工业基地可以接管整个区域。他们会把这里称为完全不适合人类居住，而这里基本上是东湾人口最稠密的住宅区。
Not only did Oakland city planners segregate this neighborhood with that highway, but they also tried to take over the area and redevelop it for more business down by the port Yeah I mean I think the the bargain essentially that the city of Oakland had been wanting to make since the early 1950s Was to sacrifice that area as a residential place and the people in it for economic growth at the port And I think what I found deeply compelling about this particular story is like, we've made that trade-off with black people so many times
奥克兰的城市规划者不仅用那条高速公路将这个社区隔离开来，他们还试图接管这片区域并将其重新开发，以便在港口附近开展更多商业活动。是的，我的意思是，我认为奥克兰市自20世纪50年代初以来一直想要达成的交易，就是为了港口的经济增长而牺牲那个地区的住宅功能以及住在那里的人们。而我认为我发现这个特定故事极其引人注目的是，我们已经很多次和黑人做过这种交易了
where we're sort of like, yeah, that's gonna hurt some black people, but we're gonna redevelop the city, right? And this is like such a pure example where people saw an economic opportunity and all that was standing in the way were some like black lives. opportunity and all that was standing in the way were some like black lives. The Port of Oakland started container operations in 1962. As the first container port on the
当时我们的态度就像是，是的，那会伤害一些黑人，但我们要重新开发这座城市，对吧？这真是一个绝佳的例子，人们看到了一个经济机会，而挡路的仅仅是一些黑人的生命。奥克兰港于1962年开始开展集装箱业务。作为美国西海岸的第一个集装箱港口，它帮助彻底改变了全球贸易。资金开始涌入湾区。但在西奥克兰，就在这个蓬勃发展的港口旁边，剩下的黑人居民却被迫忍受日益严重的污染。在当时，特别是在20世纪60年代，黑人无处可去。由于整个国家以及湾区都存在极其严厉的种族限制，根本没有他们可以居住的地方。因此，人们只能被困在那里，忍受着当地经济的这些惊人变化，其中包括大量的柴油卡车在这些被称为“短途驳运”（dredge）的短途线路上进出港口，而这些卡车可以说是你能找到的年代最久远、最脏的卡车。
west coast of the United States, it helped revolutionize global trade. Money started to pour into the Bay Area. But in West Oakland, right next to this booming port, the remaining black residents were forced to live with increasing levels of pollution. At the time, especially in the 1960s, there is nowhere for black people to go. There aren't places where they can live because of the racial restrictions that are placed across the whole country and also very strongly in the Bay Area. And so people are stuck just living with these sort of these incredible changes to the local economy, which involve tons of diesel trucks running these short routes that are called dredge, you know, in and out of ports and are kind of the oldest dirtiest trucks that you can find.
因此，西奥克兰出现了一个局部的空气质量问题，这实际上与柴油颗粒物有关。柴油颗粒物对人体有害。这有害于你的肺，会增加你患哮喘的几率，它对你的大脑也有害。我的意思是，这就是为什么人们基本上不愿意生活在污染严重的环境中的原因。但如果这是你唯一能住的地方，
And so what develops in West Oakland is a localized air quality problem that's really about diesel particulate matter. And diesel particulate matter is bad for people. Like it's bad for your lungs, increases your chance of asthma, it does bad things to your brain. I mean, there's like, it is why people don't want to live in really polluted environments, more or less. But if it's the only place you can live,
而这又是这座城市蓬勃发展的产业，你就只能被困在这里。这就是西奥克兰发生的事情。最早试图应对港口附近发生的一切的激进主义团体之一是黑豹党。该集团的总部设在西奥克兰，因此他们亲眼目睹了所有这些变化是如何影响社区中的黑人居民的。在集装箱化之前，港口一直是黑人能够找到工作的地方，但集装箱化减少了对人力的需求。
and this is the growing business of the city, you're kind of stuck. And so that's what happened in West Oakland. One of the first activist groups to try to grapple with everything happening down by the port were the Black Panthers. The group's headquarters were in West Oakland, so they witnessed firsthand how all these changes affected black residents in the neighborhood. Prior to containerization, the port had been a place where black people could find work, but containerization required less manpower.
所以现在港口既污染了社区，又抢走了人们的工作。黑豹党非常关注集装箱化正在改变奥克兰这一观点。休伊·牛顿，你知道的，他是黑豹党的主要理论家，他写了一篇名为《技术问题》的文章，我认为这篇文章极具前瞻性，并且对为什么全球供应链如此重要进行了思考。
So now the port was both polluting the neighborhood and taking jobs away from its people. The Panthers were very up on the idea that containerization was transforming Oakland. And Huey Newton, you know, who's kind of the lead theorist of the Panthers, he writes this essay called The Technology Question, which I think is just, it's so ahead of its time and kind of thinking about why global supply chains are important.
他所说的话其中之一基本上是：人们喜欢资本主义生产的那些狗屎。而这正是最棘手的部分。就像我们都喜欢这个我们并不喜欢的系统所产出的东西。那我们该怎么办呢？我想我会说，黑豹党从未真正回答过这个问题，但我们也没有。
And one of the things that he says basically is like, people like the shit that capitalism produces. And that is the trickiest component of it. Like we all like this stuff that comes out of this system that we don't like. And so what do we do about it? And I think I would say that Panther's never really answered that question, but neither have we.
我想我们所有生活在现代世界的人都在想，天哪，我不喜欢正在发生这一切。我不喜欢这个系统。我不喜欢它对天哪，我不喜欢正在发生这一切。我不 like 这个系统。我不喜欢它对人们做的事。我不喜欢它对工人们做的事。我不喜欢它对环境做的事。但我确实有最新的iPhone，我有这台电脑，
I think all of us who are living in our modern world are like, God, I don't like all this stuff that is happening. I don't like this system. I don't like what it does to God, I don't like all this stuff that is happening. I don't like this system. I don't like what it does to people. I don't like what it does to workers. I don't like what it does to environment. But I do have the latest iPhone and I have this computer
我有所有的东西。我有一辆电动汽车，你知道我的意思吗？我想我们从未真正能够解决这个问题，但他们可能是第一个如此精准地指出这一点的人。休息之后，一位西奥克兰的居民将向全球供应链发起挑战。我们欢迎亚历西斯·马德里加尔回归。
and I have all the things. I have an electric car and you know what I mean? And I think we've never really been able to tackle that thing, but they were maybe the first to like just pinpoint it so precisely. After the break, one resident of West Oakland takes on the global supply chain. We are back with Alexis Matricle.
我们在谈论他的新书《太平洋环线》。那么亚历西斯，在我们聊天的第一部分，我们讨论了从20世纪50年代开始，西奥克兰是如何被一条穿过社区正中间的高速公路隔离开来的，顺便说一句，这条高速公路本身也在加剧社区的污染。
And we're talking about his new book, The Pacific Circuit. So Alexis, in the first part of our chat, we talked about how starting in the 1950s, West Oakland was segregated by this highway that ran down through the middle of the neighborhood, which by the way, was adding to the pollution of the neighborhood in its own right.
然后邻近港口的经济繁荣随之而来，让问题变得更加严重。但你写道，在1989年，奥克兰发生了一件既充满偶然、悲惨但又具有变革意义的事件。是的，西奥克兰确实存在一个真正的“前”与“后”，因为1989年的地震导致这座高速公路倒塌了。那是尼米兹高速公路的赛普勒斯路段，因1989年的地震而坍塌。你可以看到，哦天哪，看那个。高速公路完全坍塌了。
And then this boom next door at the port comes along and adds even more to the problem. But you write about how in 1989, there's this random tragic but also transformational event that happens in Oakland. Yeah, so there's kind of a real before and after in West Oakland, which is this freeway going down because of the 1989 earthquake. That is the Cypress section of the Nimitz freeway going down because of the 1989 earthquake. That is the Cypress section of the Nimitz freeway. And you can see, oh my God, look at that. The freeway has just completely collapsed.
它以一种“机械降神”般的方式倒塌了。既然地震把它震倒了，那它原本永远不会倒塌，对吧？没有任何人会主动拆除这条连接道路，但它就这么倒塌了，并突然改变了整个社区的可能性，你知道的？当然，这种变化必须得到妥善处理，所有这些事情都必须发生。
And it comes down in this like Deus ex machina kind of way. And then since the earthquake knocks it down, it would have never come down otherwise, right? There's no way that anyone was gonna take down this like connector route, but it comes down and suddenly it changes the possibilities of the entire neighborhood, you know? And of course that change has to be managed and all these things have to happen.
但这就像是一个历史的瞬间，一夜之间，这个结构性的特征——它的根源一直追溯到把黑人隔离在西奥克兰西部的赤裸裸的种族主义建议——在某一天轰然倒塌，而该社区此后的历史，在减去这部分城市基础设施之后，变得完全不同了。
But it was just like the way that overnight, this structural feature, which has its roots all the way back in the baldly racist suggestion of segregating black people in the West part of West Oakland, it just comes down one day and the rest of the neighborhood's history henceforth, minus that piece of urban infrastructure is just different.
我的意思是，你在书中也谈到了这一点，就像那些基本上在高速公路的巨型阴影下长大、从未听过鸟鸣的人，因为周围根本没有自然。突然之间，在第一天，他们看到了光，看到了天空，听到了鸟鸣。这真的很了不起。所以这条高速公路倒塌了，带来的直接
I mean, you talk about this in your book, like people who have basically grown up in a literal shadow of a highway and they never heard birds because there was no nature around. And all of a sudden on day one, they see light, they see the sky, they hear birds. It's really something. So this highway comes down and the immediate
物理效果是西奥克兰有了更多的光线和更少的污染。但第二个不太显眼的影响是，这条高速公路消失了，在某些人看来，这感觉就像，哇，我们有了这样的机遇。有些曾经看似无法改变的事情，也许终究并非一成不变。而这种变革精神在你的书中由一个人完美地体现了出来。所以让我们向大家介绍玛格丽特·戈登女士。
physical effect is that there's a lot more light and less pollution in West Oakland. But the second less tangible effect is that this highway is gone and it feels to some people like, wow, we have this opportunity. Some things that might have felt fixed might not be so permanent after all. And that spirit of change is really embodied by one person in your book. So let's introduce everyone to Ms. Margaret Gordon.
哦，玛格丽特·戈登女士。我最初其实并没有想过要以玛格丽特女士那种方式塑造一个核心人物，但她会到处跟别人说——在我完全还没决定写什么之前——她会说：“他在写一本关于我的书。”而我会说：“好吧，你知道的，玛格丽特女士，我只想指出，我不确定这是否可以说是‘关于’你本身的，”
Oh, Ms. Margaret Gordon. I didn't actually think I was initially going to have a central character in the way that Miss Margaret became, but she would go around telling people, before I had decided this at all, she'd be like, he's writing a book about me. And I'd be like, well, you know, Miss Margaret, I just want to note, I'm not sure it's like about you per se,
但你知道，我，你知道的，而她会说：“他在写一本关于我的书。”最终结果也确实差不多就是这样。原因之一是我意识到这本书的一个备选书名可以是《人人都认识玛格丽特女士》。因为她在港口的工作，也因为她在社区里长久以来的人际关系，她把所有这些不同类型的人连接在了一起。这恰恰代表了湾区那种世纪中叶婴儿潮一代黑人经历的大量缩影，
but you know, I, you know, and she's like, he's writing a book about me. And eventually it turned out to be more or less what happened. And one reason is I realized an alternate title for this book was Everybody Knows Miss Margaret. Like she connected up all these different kinds of people because of her work out at the port, but also because of her longtime connections in the community. It just represented so much of that kind of mid-century boomer black experience in the
在那里，一个人与国家的遭遇既繁多又频繁，而且其中很多都是相当负面的。然而，从这种经历中浮现出来的，却是一个对政府行为有着惊人洞察力、并且极其擅长在某个体制的约束内运作的人——尽管这个体制或多或少想要排挤你，作为一个住在代表性不足的社区里的贫困黑人女性。你提到了玛格丽特女士与港口及社区的联系。你在书中写道，在90年代，她开始围绕空气质量问题积极参与社区活动
Bay, where somebody's encounters with the state are both voluminous and they have lots of them, and many of them are quite negative. And yet, what emerges out of that is someone with an incredible read on governmental action and an incredible read on how to work within the constraints of a system that more or less wants to exclude you as a poor black woman in a neighborhood that's not represented very well. You mentioned Ms. Margaret's connections with the port and to the neighborhood. And in your book, you write about how in the 90s, she started to get active in the community
你能多跟我讲讲那个吗？我的意思是，当时她正为她的一个孩子苦恼，并试图在学校系统里为之发声。然后她走进西奥克兰的学校，比如，护士那里有一个大大的、
around this air quality problem. Could you tell me more about that? I mean, she was at that time kind of struggling with one of her kids and was trying to be an advocate in the school system. And then she'd go into the schools in West Oakland and like, you know, the nurse would have like a big, you know, basket of inhalers labeled with all the kids' names.
贴着所有孩子名字标签的吸入器篮子。她就会问：“为什么所有这些孩子都有哮喘？”当你提到孩子们有哮喘时，你是说当时确实存在一场哮喘危机？就像当时的一些研究表明，西奥克兰的哮喘发病率是州平均水平的七倍左右。是的，所以在西奥克兰很长一段时间里，人们都知道空气不好。
And she'd be like, well, why is it that like all these kids have asthma? And when you say the kids had asthma, you mean there was really an asthma crisis. Like at the time, some studies showed that asthma rates in West Oakland were like seven times the state average. Yeah, so for a long time in West Oakland, people knew that the air wasn't good.
但当然，随着时间的推移，所有这些东西会产生累积影响。卡车交通量随着时间的推移不断增加。由于这是一个基本上为了该地区的经济增长而被牺牲的社区，它真的被当成狗屎一样对待，你知道的？所以最终发生的事情是，玛格丽特女士
But of course, there's cumulative impacts of all this stuff over time. There's just the increase in truck traffic that occurred over time. And because it was a neighborhood that was essentially sacrificed for the economic growth of the region, it was really treated like shit, you know? And so what ends up happening is that Miss Margaret,
与其他一些人一起，想要着手弄清楚——这个社区到底发生了什么？比如，这座城市对这个社区是如何运作的或它需要什么并没有很好的认知。因此，他们联合起来创建了后来被称为“西奥克兰环境指标项目”的组织。而这个“环境指标”正是他们最初追求的目标。
along with some other folks, want to get like a handle on like, well, what's happening in this neighborhood? Like, the city does not have good visibility into like how this neighborhood works or what it needs. And so they join up together to create this thing that's eventually called the West Oakland Environmental Indicators Project. And that environmental indicators is sort of what they were first after. together to create this thing that's eventually called the West Oakland Environmental Indicators Project.
他们基本上做了调查工作，数了卡车，查阅了政府数据资料，并创建了这样一套基本上表明“这些是我们社区不好的地方，这些是好的地方，这是我们的优势，我们想要改变这些事情”的指标。几乎立刻就很清楚的是，问题真的出在卡车上。是的，你在书中有一个统计数据，
And that environmental indicators is sort of what they were first after. They basically did survey work, they counted trucks, they looked at government data sources, and they create this essentially set of indicators that says, like, these are the things that are bad in our neighborhood, these are the things that are good, here's our strengths, we want to change these things. And it became clear pretty much right away that it was really about the trucks. Yeah, and you have this stat in your book
显示西奥克兰每天有数千车次的卡车穿过社区。因为我的意思是，当时很大一部分经济都与这个港口息息相关。所以进出这个社区的货物数量简直是难以想象的。完全如此。所以卡车在整个社区到处弄得一团糟，压裂了人行道，
that West Oakland had like thousands of truck trips going through the neighborhood every day. Because I mean, at the time, so much of the economy was tied to this port. So the number of things going in and out of this neighborhood is kind of unimaginable. Totally. And so the trucks were just like making a mess all over the neighborhood, cracking sidewalks,
在你的门外怠速排放废气，诸如此类。当然，污染本身——这对所有住在那里的人来说都是显而易见的，并且作为直接后果正在损害社区儿童的健康。所以这个团体基本上成了西奥克兰最关键的环境正义压力集团，他们对市政府说，对奥克兰港说，将他们架在火上烤，你们必须采取行动。比如你们不能在计划中默认我们健康状况恶劣。你们必须把净化这里的空气纳入考量，即使你们想要促进当地的经济增长。所以在这个团体成立后不久，玛格丽特·戈登从社区活动家转变为另一个角色，
idling outside your door and all that kind of stuff. And of course, the pollution itself, which was obvious to everyone who was living there and it was as a direct consequence was harming the health of the children in the neighborhood. And so that group essentially becomes the key environmental justice pressure group in West Oakland saying to the city, saying to the Port of Oakland, holding their feet to the fire, you must do something. Like you cannot assume our bad health in your plans. You must account for cleaning up the air and this place even as you want the economy to grow in the area So not too long after lunch of this group Margaret Gordon moves from community activists into another role
在这个角色中，她对港口发生的事情真正有了一些发言权，她成了一名港口专员。所以你能跟我讲讲她被任命为这个职务的重要性吗？你知道，对于西奥克兰来说，这个对他们的生活产生如此巨大影响的港口董事会里，从来没有过社区代表，对吧？但社区里没有人真正坐在那个位置上。董事会总是由房地产开发商和商界人士组成，可以说是城市的精英。因此，能让一个来自该地区、
Where she really had some say over what happens down at the port and she becomes a port commissioner And so can you tell me about the significance of her getting appointed to that position? You know for West Oakland there had never been a community representative on this port board, which is just having such a big impact on their lives, right? But no one from the community was actually ever there. It was always like real estate developers and business people, kind of the elite of the city. So to have someone from the area who
就住在第七街、一直应对着所有这些影响的人进入董事会，对西奥克兰来说是一件大事。我认为对玛格丽特来说，这确实是她职业生涯的巅峰，就拥有制度性权力、能够挥洒权力而言。她利用这种权力促成了这项海事空气质量改善计划的实施。这就是她控制港口排放的计划。是的。我的意思是，随着他们制定的变革和改革方案逐步推出，多年来这实际上转化为：柴油颗粒物的排放量——也就是，
lives right on 7th Street, who's been dealing with all those impacts on the board, which is a huge deal for West Oakland. And I think for Margaret, it really was the kind of high point of her career in terms of having, you know, institutional power, power that could be wielded. And she used it to help get this maritime air quality improvement plan instituted. And this was like her plan to rein in emissions from the port. Yeah. I mean, what that actually has translated into over the years as the changes and reforms
你知道的，卡车排放的大部分东西——下降了98%，至少从某些指标来看是这样。总体而言，社区内的排放量大幅下降，我的意思是，空气质量得到了巨大的改善。我真的认为，甚至连港口本身也将此归功于这项海事空气质量改善计划，这可以说是玛格丽特引以为傲的最高成就。所以我只是觉得，你知道，这是那种感觉如此重要的事情，
that they made have rolled out was that emissions from diesel particulates, so that's, you know, most of the stuff coming out of the trucks, fell 98%, at least by some measures. And overall, emissions in the neighborhood fell by a lot, I mean, huge improvement in air quality. And I really do think even the port itself traces it to this maritime air quality improvement plan, which was sort of Margaret's crowning achievement. So I just think, you know, it's one of those things that feels so important,
尽管它只是，你知道的，一个人进入了一个董事会，但这个人产生了影响，因为她了解其他人在社区层面上所不知道的事情。今天，显而易见的是，玛格丽特·戈登女士为改善西奥克兰的空气质量做出了巨大的贡献。但清洁的空气并不是她所在的社区唯一需要的东西。因为正是那种把高速公路穿插镇中心、并将黑人居民困在港口旁的种族主义城市规划，也剥夺了西奥克兰的经济机会。
even though it was just, you know, one person getting onto a board, but that person made an impact because they knew things about what were happening at the neighborhood level that other people didn't. Today it's clear that Ms. Margaret Gordon has done a ton to improve the air quality in West Oakland. But clean air isn't the only thing her neighborhood needs. Because the same racist city planning that put a highway through the middle of the town and trapped black residents next to the port also deprived West Oakland of economic opportunities.
而这两件事情——对清洁空气的需求和对工作岗位的需求——在奥克兰这样地方很难平衡。亚历西斯的书里有一个故事完美地说明了这种动态，它与围绕港口附近一个退役陆军基地的争夺战有关。这场争端将一位炙手可热的当地开发商菲尔·塔加米（Phil Tagami）推向了玛格丽特女士的对立面。
And those two things, the need for clean air and the need for jobs, can be hard to balance in a place like Oakland. There's a story in Alexis's book that really illustrates this dynamic and it has to do with the battle over a decommissioned army base down by the port. The dispute pits a hotshot local developer, Phil Tagami, up against Ms. Margaret.
塔加米的计划是利用老陆军基地所在的土地来扩建港口并创造更多就业机会。玛格丽特女士则想要一个同样能让她的社区受益的计划，但在经历了多年争取清洁空气的斗争之后，她理所当然地有一些担忧。这是一个非常有趣的情况，在那片土地上发生了什么，
Tagami's plan wants to use the land the old army base sits on to expand the port and create more jobs. Ms. Margaret wants a plan that benefits her community too, but she understandably, after years of fighting for clean air, has some concerns. It's such an interesting situation, what happened out there,
因为在我的脑海里，你基本上有两个人物，他们确实是真正的奥克兰人——他们深深扎根于奥克兰社区，两人都有着超级深厚的根基，但他们又是如此的不同。他们简直是——太不同了，你知道的，玛格丽特女士是西奥克兰的环境正义领袖，而另一位是菲尔·塔加米，他有点像是那种市中心的开发商，但他自己却没有上过大学，是从做科技地产起步的开发商，一步步爬上来，最终成为了重建福克斯剧院的人——那是市中心一座古老而美丽的剧院，
because you essentially have two figures in my mind who Really are Oakland people like they're deep in the Oakland community both of them have these Super deep roots, but they're so different. They're just so so different, you know, Miss Margaret Environmental Justice leader West Oakland and then you have kind of Phil Tagami who's this kind of downtown Developer but who himself like didn't go to college, worked his way up as a developer doing tiki-tech stuff into eventually being the guy who redid the Fox Theater, you know, one of these old, beautiful theaters,
现在你知道的，它成了奥克兰市中心一个绝佳的音乐演出场所。然后他把目标死死锁定在这个陆军基地的项目上，并基本上与许多工会组织等达成了一项在当时相当具有创新性的协议，他们获得了很大比例的当地雇佣名额。所以你知道的，项目区附近的人将被雇用。他们同意了一大堆奥克兰和东湾工会
which is now, you know, this amazing music venue in downtown Oakland. And then he locks his jaws onto this project of the Army base and essentially cuts what's really quite an innovative deal at the time with a lot of labor groups and stuff where they got a huge percentage of local hire. So you know, people from near the project area would get hired. They agreed to a whole bunch of stuff that the labor groups of Oakland and the East Bay
真正想要的东西，对吧？但那里仍然存在着一个环境方面的眼中钉，在追求在后金融危机时代将这些工作岗位带入奥克兰的急切心情中，玛格丽特女士觉得那一部分被顺手抹掉了，你知道的，我不知道人们是否还记得，提供高薪工作是奥巴马时代的那种流行口号之一。
really wanted, right? But there was still this kind of environmental thorn in the side and it felt to Ms. Margaret that that kind of got brushed aside in the rush to deliver these jobs in the sort of like post financial crisis years, you know, into Oakland, where I don't know if people remember, but there was a good paying jobs was like one of those
你知道的，这就是这个项目所要兑现的承诺，整个地方权力结构都在支持它。他们支持塔加米做所有这些事情。而玛格丽特则有点被挤到了一边，她的环境担忧在某种程度上被，你知道的，扫进了地毯底下。是的，这一切在一个特定问题上达到了白热化，因为人们发现，将通过这个新扩建的港口进行航运的其中一个待选货物竟然是煤炭。咚，咚，咚。
like kind of catch phrases of the Obama era. And you know, that's what this was delivering the whole local power structure was behind it. They were behind Tagami doing all this stuff. And Margaret kind of got pushed to the side and her environmental concerns were sort of, you know, swept under the rug. Yeah, and this all came to a head with one particular issue, because one of the things that was discovered that would be on the table for shipping through this newly expanded port was coal. Dun, dun, dun.
是的，没错。就像今年，各俱乐部在奥克兰有了他们新的全国总部。你知道我的意思吗？这是全国大城市中最反川普的地方。我想我们在2016年的时候，投票反对川普的比例达到了96%，这次也差不多。这就像是一个反——就像你无法想象一个比这里更不愿意让煤炭成为我们当地经济一部分的地方。
Yeah, right. It's like this year, clubs got their new national headquarters in Oakland. You know what I mean? It's like the most anti-Trump place, a major city in the country. I think we went in 2016, I think we went 96% against Trump and it's pretty similar this time. This is like the anti, like you cannot imagine a place I think that would be less amenable to wanting to have coal be like part of our local economy.
因此，这个出口码头基本上会让运煤列车直接穿过西奥克兰。所以人们非常、非常愤怒，举行了所有这些市议会会议，发生了所有这些事情。这是城市历史上的那些时刻之一，你会突然意识到：天哪，一座城市到底能做什么？如果一座城市无法阻止这一点——而整个城市都对此坚决反对——
And so this export terminal would essentially have run coal cars right through West Oakland. So people were very, they were big mad and there were all these city council meetings and there's all this stuff. It's one of those moments in a city's history where you just realize like, oh man, what can a city do? Like if a city can't stop this, which the entire city is opposed to,
那么这说明了我们现代世界的权力是怎么一回事？完全如此，而且这也是——这一切都是全球贸易经济试图再次强行践踏西奥克兰。没错，完全如此。基本上奥克兰试图做的是——对开发商提起多起诉讼，
then what does that say about power in our modern world? Totally, and it's also like, this is all that global trade economy trying to plow its way through West Oakland again. Right, totally. And basically what Oakland has tried to do is like file multiple lawsuits against the developer,
但他们不断败诉，因为塔加米与市政府签订的合同基本上说明他可以这么做，如果他想运煤的话，他就能运。绝对的，我的意思是，诉讼接连不断，仅仅通过拖延，你就是在发动一场长期的金融围耗战。所以直到今天，在我们录音的时候，它仍然没有作为一个煤炭出口码头而存在。
but they keep losing because the contract Agami has with the city basically says that he can do it, that he can ship the coal if he wants to. Absolutely, I mean, litigation after litigation, just by delaying it, you're kind of waging like siege financial warfare. And so to this day, as we're recording here, it still doesn't exist as a coal export terminal.
它并没有，它不存在，你知道吗？多年来，这场战斗一直在继续。皮特·斯拉森。至少对我而言，关于这场围绕陆军基地的争夺战，最有趣的是这些事情往往是如何把一切都拖入停滞的。我的意思是，距离老陆军基地退役已经过去25年多了，市长和开发商仍然没有弄清楚如何利用这块土地来造福这座城市。你知道的，别误会我，我也不希望它成为一个煤炭码头。我觉得那糟透了。但我真希望这座城市能建造点什么，因为
Like it doesn't, it's not there exist as a coal export terminal. It's not there, you know? And the fight continues all these years on. Pete Slauson And at least for me, what I find so interesting about this whole fight over the Army base is just how these things have a tendency to grind everything to a halt. I mean, it's been more than 25 years since the old Army base was decommissioned and still neither the city nor the developer have figured out how to use this piece of land to benefit the city. And you know, don't get me wrong, like I don't want it to be a coal terminal either. Like I think that sucks. But I would love it if the city would build something because
在住房危机、气候危机和其它所有问题之间，我们将需要建造东西，而且要建得相当快。有时，因为我们知道我们必须为气候变化重建如此多的基础设施，我有时会担心活动人士阻止建设新事物的能力，比如输电线路和其他设施。我希望人们能从这本书中得到的收获之一，
between the housing crisis and the climate crisis and everything else, we are going to need to build things and build them pretty fast. I sometimes, because we know we have to rebuild so much infrastructure for climate change, I at times worry about the ability of activists to stop things from getting built, transmission lines, other things. And one of the things that I hope people
菲尔·塔加米在某个时刻对我说：“如果你跟罗伯特·摩西（Robert Moses）交往，你就必须用简·雅各布斯（Jane Jacobs）来漱口，或者你也可以反过来理解。”这真是一个地道的“99P”梗。我总觉得，无论你在建造东西的哪个立场上，如果你要和塔加米交往，你就得用玛格丽特女士来漱口。如果你要
would take away from this book, Phil Tagami at one point says to me, if you brush with Robert Moses, you have to rinse with Jane Jacobs, or you could have gotten it the other way. That's a real 99P reference there for you. And I kind of feel like wherever you are on the spectrum of building stuff, if you're going to brush with Tagami, you've got to rinse with Miss Margaret. If you're going to spectrum of building stuff, if you're gonna brush with Togami, you gotta rinse with Miss Margaret.
和玛格丽特女士交往，你就得用塔加米来漱口，因为尝试建造一堆新东西（而我们确实知道我们实际上需要这么做）本质上是一件不同的事情。我们实际上不能把一切都冻结起来。所以对我来说，这与其说是什么英雄与恶棍的故事——尽管其中包含这种成分——
If you're gonna brush with Miss Margaret, you gotta rinse with Togami, because it is fundamentally kind of a different thing to try to build a whole bunch of new stuff, which we do know we actually need to do. We cannot actually just freeze everything. So for me, it's almost like it's less, you know, like hero and villain, although there's that component to it.
不如说更像是：这些人中的每一个人都包含着未来世界所需的一部分。而必须存在的东西是：你必须真正为你所在的这个地方谋求美好的事物——虽然这一点在所有情况下我都不太确定，不过呢，你知道的，人们可以通过不同的方式通往一个美好的世界，你知道的，而我仍然希望菲尔放弃这个项目，然后大家都能庆祝一番。嗯。
And it's more like each of these people contains a piece of what the future world needs to be. And the thing that must be there is you must actually want good things for the place where you are, which is not, I'm not always sure about that in all cases, but then, you know, people can have different ways of getting to like a good world, you are, which is not, I'm not always sure about that in all cases. But then, you know, people can have different ways of getting to, like, a good world, you know, and I'm still hoping that Phil gives up on the project and everyone can celebrate. Mm-hmm.
这更像是每个人都携带着未来世界所需的一部分。并且必须具备的条件是，你必须真正为自己身处的地方祈愿美好，这一点——说实话，我并非在所有情况下都能确定这一点。但你知道，人们可以通过不同的方式去达成一个美好的世界，你知道的，我依然希望菲尔能放弃那个项目，然后大家都可以庆祝。嗯哼。
Yeah. So we've talked about, I don't know, like, 100 years of Oakland history. How do you think this global economic order that was born right here out of those cranes by the port? How do you think it's changed life in the city? I think to get to you know an obvious point about Oakland that must be addressed it's like Oakland has swapped out a huge percentage of its population for higher income less black people and We have really brutal crime still and now I think demographically shocking the income levels of Oakland relative to its crime rates. I think
是的。我们讨论了，我不知道，大概100年的奥克兰历史。你认为这种在全球经济秩序下诞生于港口起重机旁的模式，是如何改变这座城市的生活的？我认为要谈到奥克兰一个显而易见且必须面对的问题，那就是奥克兰已经用更高收入、更少黑人的群体置换了很大一部分人口，而且我们依然有着非常残酷的犯罪问题，现在我认为从人口统计学来看，奥克兰的收入水平与其犯罪率相比，令人震惊。我认为
people, it's almost like an outlier in that way. The city could not gentrify its way to safety, security, and vibrancy. Instead, we gentrified the hell out of Oakland, and there's empty stores everywhere, empty ground floor retail everywhere. We've got high real estate prices and low everything else. And it's like, as long as things are market-driven in this way, the only thing rich people can do to a place is make the price go up. And I think everyone who lives in poor neighborhoods knows that, which is why gentrification has the name that it does,. And I think everyone who lives in poor neighborhoods knows that, which is why gentrification
人们，从某种意义上说它几乎是一个特例。这座城市无法通过士绅化来实现安全、稳定和充满活力。相反，我们把奥克兰的士绅化推向了极致，结果到处都是空置的商店，到处都是空置的底商。我们拥有高昂的房地产价格，而其他一切都很低迷。这就好比，只要事物继续以这种市场驱动的方式运作，富人对一个地方唯一能做的事就是让价格上涨。我想住在贫困社区的每个人都知道这一点，这就是为什么士绅化会有这样的名声。我想住在贫困社区的每个人都知道这一点，这就是为什么士绅化
has the name that it does, even though I think on its own terms, trying to fight gentrification in the narrow sense by keeping urban change from happening has failed. And you can look around and see the results of that. And so I kind of feel like we might be at a bit of like a low point for this, like how we think about what needs to change in cities because we're kind of at a bit of like a low point for this, like how we think about what needs to change in cities
会有这样的名声，尽管我认为就其本身而言，试图通过阻止城市变迁来狭隘地反对士绅化已经失败了。你可以环顾四周并看到这种结果。所以我有点觉得，我们可能正处于一个低谷期，关于我们如何思考城市需要发生什么改变，因为我们正处于这样一个低谷期，关于我们如何思考城市需要发生什么改变
because we're kind of at the end of a line of a bunch of different theories about how to make cities better. And now we get to try something else. Well, Alexis, thank you so much for talking with me. Thanks so much for the book. I really enjoyed our conversation. I appreciate it.
因为我们差不多走到了一系列关于如何让城市变得更好的不同理论的尽头。现在我们得尝试点别的了。好的，亚历кси斯，非常感谢你与我交谈。非常感谢你的这本书。我很享受我们的对话。我很感激。
Thank you so much, talking with me. Thanks so much for the book. I really enjoyed our conversation. I appreciate it. Thank you so much, Roman. Thanks, 99PI. Alexis Madrigal's new book, The Pacific Circuit, is available everywhere right now. Go check it out. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Jason DeLeon and edited by Kelly Prime, mixed by Martin Gonzalez. Music by Swan Real. Kathy Tew is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director,
非常感谢你与我交谈。非常感谢你的这本书。我很享受我们的对话。我很感激。非常感谢你，罗曼。谢谢你，99PI。亚历克斯·马德里加尔的新书《环太平洋路线》现在在各地均有销售。快去看看吧。本周的《99%隐形》由杰森·德莱昂制作，凯利·普莱姆编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。音乐由斯旺·里尔创作。凯西·休是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，
Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barupe, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lashma Dawn, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on Blue Sky as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
德兰妮·霍尔是我们的资深编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁佩、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉什玛·道恩、乔·罗森伯格、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯设计。我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一员，现在总部设在美丽的加州奥克兰上城区潘多拉大厦向北六个街区的地方。你可以在 Blue Sky 以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。在 99PI.org 上有一个指向该服务器以及 99PI 每一期过往节目的链接。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。